Bark is hard to listen to,
you have to listen to his pieces over
and over.
At least I do.
I don't suppose you have to if you're a
musical genius,
but because goal interpreted them
personally,
it was easier to take the music apart
and understand in an auditory way what
Bach was trying to do.
Music helps demonstrate the reality of
meaning and it does that for everyone
that does that.
For people who are deeply atheistic or
even nihilistic,
and that's interesting too because you
can take bitterly disaffected punk
rockers and they listen to music and
they're overwhelmed by a sense of it's
really a sense of religious meaning they
don't even notice it except that without
it they'd be in trouble.
Some people who are low in openness,
which is a psychological trait and
they're pretty opaque to what art
represents and so they have a hard time
with it or maybe they need more less
sophisticated art.
It's too shocking to them if it's
sophisticated in and profound,
they can't handle it.
Lots of people are terrified by art and
they like things.
They like music.
They like catch because if it's real,
it's too much for them.
They're terrified of it.
They'll say,
I don't like that.
It's like,
isn't that they don't like it.
It's that they can't handle it.
They're afraid of people are even afraid
of color.
You know?
That's why everybody uses Bayesian.
They're decorating and creams,
you know,
they're terrified of color,
so people are terrified of deep truths
and wonder so they.
They wouldn't be deep if they weren't
terrifying.
When we look at the world,
we see objects,
handleable and usable objects in motion,
but that isn't really what the world is
like.
What the world is like is a set of
interlocking and interconnected patterns
at multiple levels of resolution from
the tiniest to the largest all playing
together in a patterned and somewhat
predictable manner,
not completely predictable,
like music isn't completely predictable,
and so the reason that music is
meaningful when you listen to it is
because music demonstrates to you what
the structure of the university is
actually like and your senses.
Your visual sense blinds you to that
because it's more practical in a way.
It shows you what you need to live right
now,
whereas music gives you this sculptural
picture of quantized patterns
interacting at multiple levels of
analysis simultaneously,
and that infuses people with a sense of
meaning are truly artistic.
Production is full of inarticulate,
meaning it's inarticulate because it's.
It's.
It's still in the developmental stage
before articulate knowledge and so it
grips people with a sense of
significance,
but they can't necessarily say why and
the reason they can't say yes because
the why for that kind of meaning hasn't
been explicated yet.
The reason that art
is meaningful to people is because art
is meaningful.
It's full of the next set of ideas.
That's one way of looking about it or
it's or it's full of eternal ideas that
people still haven't fully comprehended
and so you can't help but be gripped by
it.